اذا ومعكم في هذه الصور نتابعها مباشره
حيث نرصد لكم لحظه بلحظه عبر شبكه
الصحفيين الذين انضموا معنا وشاركوا معنا
في هذه التغطيه عهد صليبي يتابع معنا وعبر
شاشه العربيه لمحاوله انقاذ شخص من تحت
الانقاض في انطاكيا بعد سبعه ايام من
الزلزال في هذا المبنى المكون تقريبا من
عشره طوابق طبعا تم انتشال عدد من الجثث
ولكن تم رصد والوصول الى شخص على قيد
الحياه نتحدث عن رجل 50 في العمر رغم مضي
سبعه ايام على هذا الزلزال المدمر الذي
وقع في السادس من فبراير وضرب الجنوب
التركي وايضا الشمال السوري مناطق واحياء
عده اصبحت مدمره اصبحت منكوبه اعلنت حاله
الطوارئ في تركيا ثلاث مناطق في سوريا تم
اعلانها مناطق منكوبه حتى هذه الساعه ما
زالت تداعيات هذه الزل ولكن رغم كل الظروف
ومحاولات وعمليات الانقاذ حتى رغم فقدان
الامل بان قد يكون هناك احياء نحن في
اليوم السابع ننقل لكم بالصوره وبالاخبار
على شاشه العربيه بانه قد يكون هناك احياء
وما زالت عمليات انتشال عالقين احياء من
تحت الانقاذ مستمره حتى رغم مرور سبعه
ايام على هذا الزلزال ما زالت المعجزات
تتوالى الاخبار المبشره بان الحياه غاليه
وبان هناك اشخاص يستحقون الحياه رغم هذا
الوضع الكارسي الذي حل بالشعبين
وبالمنطقتين الى اننا ما زلنا نرصد على
الهواء مباشره لعمليات انقاذ اشخاص احياء
رغم ان فرق الدفاع المدني من كلا الجانبين
كانت تتحدث بانه تضاءلت الفرص بالوصول الى
ناجين وان الدفاع المدني السوري كان تحدث
بانه انتقلنا من مرحله عمليات الانقاذ
لانتشال اشخاص ومساعده اشخاص عالقين اسفل
وفي بين الركام والحطام الى مرحله انتشال
الجثث كان